welcome back to the toast the final
episode of the Year being made even more
special as if it wasn't special enough
we are joined by honestly someone who's
had such an impact on this show you
recognize me it is the one the only
Olivia culpa welcome to the show Olivia
thank you guys first of all I can't
believe that I've had an impact on this
show I told everybody that I was doing
this and they were peeing their pants
they are everybody adores you guys so
thank you for having me and I adore you
obviously personally but no but we're so
excited I can't believe we haven't had
you on the show yet but I do feel like
now is the perfect time you have so much
going on we have spoken about your new
show a lot here at the toast because I'm
obsessed with it and I don't just say
that like to be up your butt and stuff
like I think it's such a wonderful
joyful positive show that the world
needs more of and I think that you and
your sisters are such great role models
as individuals but also like your
sisterly Bond we are obsessed with
sisters and being sisters and watching
you in yours I just I feel like I know
what your answer is going to be because
I work with my sisters but what is it
like working with your sisters in such
an official capacity now
it's oh my gosh I can't imagine you guys
you've been doing it for so much longer
it's really it's really hard like it's
hard it's equal parts hard but equal
parts
rewarding obviously there's no love that
you have with you know anybody else in
the world that's like the love you have
for your sister you would die for them
but equal parts you're gonna call them
out on every single piece of [ __ ]
that they throw your way
um so yeah it's like it really is both
bad and good
and how are they like this is not so new
for you like you've been around the
block you've been around for a long time
and I feel like being on TV is a level
up and for your sisters I feel like it's
much more of a jump how are they dealing
with it because people can be like you
know when you open up your lives you're
opening yourself up just like some
really awful people saying awful things
about you and your sisters how are they
dealing with it I think they're they're
good at it honestly they're good at
being
the [ __ ] I think that it's because
we're insulated by by each other in a
lot of ways because it's not even just
us we also have my two brothers and my
parents like they're we're one of five
so there's they help as well like
there's really no Rock Bottom when you
know at least you're gonna have each
other at the end so when you are dealing
with the [ __ ] when people are being
horrible because they feel horrible
themselves uh you just have to remember
and keep that in mind and we help each
other and you guys know because you face
it too you've been doing this for so
long it's like some days you wake up and
you're and you can take on the world and
other days you wake up and somebody can
tell you that like you have a dead end
on your hair and you like want to cry
you know no it's so true it depends on
the day I know so the three of us and
I'm sure it's the same with you guys
like every day somebody's having a good
day or a bad day and the people the
person having a good day will lift up
the others and it really is like that
this weird cycle of I'll call my sister
and I'll be in a really bad place about
some things that I'm reading or doing or
not getting and she'll be in a really
good place and she'll remind me of the
truth and then other times she'll be in
the dark and I'll remind her of the
truth which is just that you know you
have to just be happy to be here and
doing what you are have set out to do
and like it's like the man in the arena
quote I always I have it on the back of
my phone but yeah Roosevelt quote but
also in general it's like if you can't
handle the heat you have to get out of
the kitchen and you have to remember
that at the end of the day it's a
privilege to be able to take chances in
the way that we are in any capacity and
you should just be proud of that and
really try to think about that and the
haters are gonna hate no matter what
that's a really good way of looking at
it you have had such an amazing career I
feel like sometimes you have to remind
ourselves that you came from Miss USA to
start and then you've been an influencer
for so many years and an actress and
even though you for the last few years
have been sharing your life on Instagram
and I feel like we get to know you so
well now being on a reality show you are
sharing so much more how has that
transition been for you to open up
yourself like that
it's been challenging but mostly
challenging because I have a lot of well
for the people in my life who are not
will who don't want to be on a reality
show like my boyfriend for example like
things like that have been challenging
because I don't want to exploit the
privacy of people that I care about by
when I'm sharing my point of view so
just walking that very fine line but as
far as myself I am an open book and I
think this has been an opportunity that
has scared me because of the
vulnerability involved in it and
um having to take everything up a level
in the in the storytelling of my life
but I like that I actually feel like
I've always been an open book in that
way and I I do I have to say I enjoy it
scary we enjoy it too and I feel like
when you think about like your favorite
influencer and thinking about them being
on a reality show oftentimes it would
wind up being disappointing but your
life and your family life and I feel
like your interior life too it's just
it's not just entertaining but it's
really like I don't know to how to
describe it other than like joyful and
real like that's how real sisters are
with each other like you guys are so
hard working but you also know how to
have fun and like enjoy all of the
things that you've earned for yourselves
thanks I I feel like that's a very
that's a very very very nice compliment
and
where I came from is so different from
my life now I mean I think for I'm sure
for everyone it is right but it's um
it's cool to be able to share people
it's cool to be able to share that with
people especially my parents they're
just so out of this world they're so
sweet
I love when they're on the show they
give like really great advice and also
they offer such a great perspective
because it's like this really grounding
these two really grounding people who
like come into your La world and kind of
you realize how it's so dissimilar to
the real world for some people but I
think having them there is it's a
perfect formula I know it's true they
really they really are grounding they
will humble you very quickly they always
have a way of reframing everything to
make you feel like oh yeah this really
isn't a big deal like my problems are
not as big as I think they are and
it's helpful it is yeah well I'm really
glad you brought up your boyfriend
because I don't know if you know like a
fun fact about the toast is that we
fully support the 49ers and that's
because Kyle just check and his wife are
toasters and we just like love to see
toasters out on the field doing their
thing and now that your man's place for
the 49ers and like you're spending a lot
of time in San Fran it's just it's so
much better like it's fabulous and I
want to know like what your thoughts are
on Sanford and I know it's easier for
you to get there now from La yeah I love
these the word fabulous football is
fabulous
it is I know I I have to say I love it I
love the 49ers I love the bang bang
Niner gang
um it's fun we had a team that's winning
I have to say I mean I'm true yeah
winning is better than losing and
they've been doing that lately so I'm so
grateful I'm so so happy in the flight
the flight is so much easier for me
um
everything about it is easier people
lately have been like you look so like
rested and something's different about
you it's like oh yeah because I'm not
getting on a five and a half hour flight
every week to go to Charlotte that was I
lit that truly took years off my life
like it I had to do that for three years
I love Charlotte dearly and I love
everybody there so much but that five
and a half it's so bad that's love I
know I love when you get there your
whole day is gone like I would leave at
eight and I would get there at like four
because the time change yeah because
when you fly west to east it sucks you
like lose your whole day it was the
whole day I would leave my house when
it's dark out and I would get there when
it's dark so that's right
yeah yeah New Beginnings
do you feel like the reception to the
show and like how
well everyone is like loving it it's
gonna make some of the more reticent
people in your life or even like maybe
people that you work with
feel more comfortable joining the show I
feel like we always hear that about like
real housewives how like in the
beginning they weren't allowed to film
here or there but then like once you see
how much support it has and how beloved
it is now like everybody wants in on it
I know that's so true I I absolutely
think so I think my boyfriend's mom will
want to be on it that would be really
funny my boyfriend your content with her
is so premium oh my God one of the
craziest things about you is that you
quarantined with your boyfriend's family
for like a hundred days right with and
with your sister and that you guys
didn't and that there wasn't a murder
and I think that's amazing it's huge
there wasn't a murder that was an
interesting time to be honest with you
there was a lot of uh
there was a lot of surviving not driving
but no I love them we got so close I
feel like if you can go through a
pandemic with someone you can get
through anything like going to the
grocery store and feeling like okay that
was that's it I'm gonna die now like
literally when we're going out and just
being like this is really [ __ ] scary
yeah yeah know your content with your
boyfriend's mom is so premium and I feel
like not a lot of people have that so
it's really nice oh thanks yes she's a
character I feel like she would be the
star of the show so I would love to see
her I would love totally more of
Christian I think that maybe I I agree
everybody was really scared at the
beginning when this show was about to
come out and I was so grateful that they
actually had uh they they were
pleasantly surprised that doesn't always
happen and I don't see the episodes
before they air so I have no idea what's
going to get out there and how it's
going to be portrayed and they could
spin things in a bunch of different ways
so every so anyway it was overall a good
experience and I definitely think that
if there are enough maybe I can even get
you know some of the other 49ers on the
on the show imagine I feel like do you
know Christian juice check I feel like
sure I love it I maybe she would love it
right I think so the toast brings people
together so we could arrange it honestly
really oh 100 but we would obviously
have to be there like
can I ask you a question like more in
general about your career I feel like
it's been so interesting to follow like
Jackie said I feel like a lot of people
don't even remember that you really got
your start and your platform from the
pageant circuit and then you've got more
into influencing and now reality star
and I feel like I remember a shift in
your content a few years ago where you
were really actively including your
sisters and your content and of course
we loved it because we found it so
relatable and I'm curious if that was
like a conscious decision for you or it
was just like naturally like I'm with my
sister so I might as well make them film
with me
it was 100
organic so my older sister Aurora she
actually was Private until like three or
four years ago
um so at that point before that point
there was actually a lot of tension
between us because she thought that what
I was doing was face senseless and Vain
and vapid and she was going through this
whole like Yogi Guru I don't know this
weird food yeah you know like one of
those and she was like my sister only
wears crop tops and she's so interested
all she does is take pictures it's like
okay well anyway anyway she gets it now
it's not just writing pictures it's you
know building a relationship with people
and you guys understand that yeah but
um so I I ended up when she got the
stick out of her ass I started doing
more content around around her and like
I would just be more comfortable so
since she was in this the content and
then with my younger sister she was in
college not that long ago
so I was living in La she was living in
Boston at college and then when she
finally got out of college she moved in
with me so that was around the same time
so it all kind of happened very
organically because we've always been
equally close we've always been I've
always considered them to be like my
best friends in the world but I think I
guess in some ways Instagram has brought
us together because we were all having
so much fun sharing with people because
like if one of them were like I don't
want to be on your Instagram then I
don't know if you know this obviously
wouldn't have happened the way that it
did but we ended up having a ton of fun
together and just being
I don't know stupid
I kind of would have loved to see the
show though like back when Aurora you
said your words not mine had to stick up
her ass like I think that would have
been hilarious I know like every time I
would go over to like oh my God you're
in another crop top why are you in
another problem and now all she wears is
crop top that's one example of when she
has the stick up brass era which she's
very she might not admit it but she will
she said not her launching a war on crop
tops even though I fully support that
movement I'm still over crop tops like
some House of big tits we can't just
wear crop tops you know right like you
have a perfect ass and you're wearing a
crop top get out of here right I don't
have a perfect ass by the way so
some of us have jugs like we can't just
be walking around in a bra you know
show is really so good I feel like this
has been like a great era for you and
it's just nice to see like we've met you
actually we have like a running joke on
the toast the first time we met you what
year was it Jackie at Coachella it was
coach it was our first time maybe so
maybe that was 2017 Khan and we met at
the porta potties right we did classic
us so on brand and we obviously were
like loved your Instagram and we loved
you and you came over and said hi and we
could we walked away and we were like
Shaggy like she came up to you like she
recognized recognizes you and we just
kept saying it on the show and now it's
like a running joke on the show you
recognize me and it started with you
I remember that day I remember the shirt
I was wearing that's so weird
Coachella I'm not sure what I was
wearing too are you are you still on the
Coachella train are you over it
honestly I never really fully got on the
train but I it gives me a lot of anxiety
I like to do puzzles like at my house
I'm That Kind of a person and you know I
know I'm like I am such a homebody but I
when I'm there I have fun but it's like
the leading up to it where I just I fear
a lot like I fear the hangovers I fear
the walking I fear the walking I feel
hitchhiking that I'll have to do to
leave the you know like you just never
know but um I don't know I like it I
like it I'm trying to to like it more so
that I can appear and feel cooler but
it's also like an important part of your
job
yeah and I have to say I brought my
sisters this last year and it was the
best Coachella I've ever had so that is
also the other part of having them
around that I really like it's like a
security blanket I like having them with
me wherever I go and that's another
reason why we did the show together I I
love being with them it's my favorite
they're my favorite people to be with
besides my dog we actually just had that
conversation on the toast yesterday
talking about how like we have the
privilege of like going to like events
and stuff and our plus ones being other
influencers who are also our sisters and
it almost feels like you cheat the
system when you don't have to go to
those events alone and like ah like be
so those events can be so awkward when
everyone's there by themselves and
you're just like hey I'm glad yeah like
it's painful
um so being able to have like a built-in
plus one who's also very much like in
the scene and in the industry is like I
feel like I'm cheating I know we are
kind of cheating and but why I know I've
gone to so many events that have like
ruined events for me because people have
been rude and I just and then of course
and then you're scared you're scared
they ruined it so maybe yeah no it's
like a little intimidating
totally yeah that's a good takeaway in
general
and I think the the most relatable
um storyline on the show is the stealing
of clothing oh my god oh yeah
like like
as sisters we actually don't fight we
really don't fight for sisters like it's
crazy that's the only thing that like
gets us so fired up it's so crazy what
is it about stealing clothes
for me I I would let them borrow
anything it's the first of all ask of
course of course
but you don't ask and then also they or
if they wear something before I've worn
it because that's what I have to wear it
yeah
it's insane oh like she's done the
craziest [ __ ] she's photoshopped photos
so that I don't know that it's my bag
that was crazy she took a picture in
Olivia's bag and she Photoshopped it but
like it's clear that she got like it was
you know what I expect the hustle the
creativity
well you know what the thing is if she
texted texted me I would have absolutely
let her wear it of course the lack of
confrontations anybody listening who's
like extremely non-confrontational would
probably go that route but you could
just send a text yeah you could no why
would you she's such a little sister she
actually reminds me of our little sister
so much and one thing I noticed on the
show is I feel like when she's with you
guys she's like in little sister mode
and then when you see her in her scenes
like on her own and with her boyfriend
like she really like is a different
person and I feel like that or how I
would describe our little sister like
with us she's just like constantly like
getting picked on and then she goes out
into the world and it's like who's that
yes so true
and then you feel bad because you feel
like oh they don't want to be with me
right now maybe that's because I'm
stifling them that's exactly it that's
exactly it
truly I know I've noticed that too and I
do feel bad about that but I agree I
feel like as somebody that's just her
sister watching her life it is very
interesting and she's in the thick of it
it's like the ugly part where she
doesn't know what she's doing and why
she's doing it and she hasn't figured
out she hasn't figured out her her
confidence is not there yet you know
that takes so much time and also she's
doing so many new things so I feel like
I'm really excited to see where this all
um how this all IRS out for her because
I know it's going to be really cool to
watch and I'm gonna be proud of her and
to have it all on camera it's cool
because other people will be able to see
a little bit of themselves in it you're
right it is such a little sister thing
she's a snitch she's a snitch yeah we
call her little sister the snitch and
she's not that little either she's like
26. yeah every time we talk about her
people think we're talking about like an
eight-year-old
um and then we like show them a picture
they're like that's literally a 25 year
old woman that's a grown ass woman well
they're bratty like the little sisters
are bratty right yes and by the way
Olivia we had Emma Chamberlain on our
show and Margot our little sister loves
Emma Chamberlain so when we wrapped the
interview we were like Emma like our
little sister is obsessed with you like
do you mind just like if she pops on the
zoom and says hi and Emma was like of
course and she was actually expecting
like a toddler to come out the way we
were talking about her and it's like
Margo who's at the time she was like 24
she was like wearing a like a Blazer and
she's like she's like she's taller than
both of us
yeah
funny
you do is so funny literally she's a
giant
with a perfect body compared to us
so congrats on the show it's so good we
love to see just like you thriving out
there we can't wait for season two and
thank you for coming on the toast this
is actually like a huge deal for us like
a real feel full circle moment totally
they say don't podcast With Your Heroes
but they're lying they do say that they
never met Olivia Culpo ever
I'm so proud of you guys being able to
watch where how big you've blown this
thing up I mean that made no sense but
you've blown this [ __ ] up thank you oh
my god thank you in the beginning so I'm
very very proud of you guys I love the
podcast I don't understand how you talk
so fast both of you I know but you like
it's great it's something we're actively
working on
but the thing is if we talked any slower
the episodes would be two and a half
hours instead of one and a half
power well the good thing about
podcasting is that you can make your
speed like half you could double it so
there's something for everyone yeah if
it's really a problem
I literally love it like gets me excited
and it wakes me up and it I mean it's
more information in the smaller amount
of time
right so that's what we're trying to do
sorry we're efficient we're efficient
like sue us yeah
um thank you again so much for coming on
everyone check out the Copo sisters show
it's so good it's on TLC and thank you
so much for being here it's it's
pleasure
thank you bye everyone this is our final
episode wait Olivia before we let you go
our final episode of the year we are
gonna have you make a toast with us what
are you toasting to in the new year
oh my gosh I have to think about it I
I really want to work on not
bad-mouthing like I'm actually all my
friends are like you never talk [ __ ]
about anybody but I want to be even
better I don't want to have any bad
thoughts about anything and anyone I
just want to I want to minimize my
negativity
could never be me but I wish you the
best of luck and that sounds amazing and
you're better than all of us but we
already knew that
thank you guys for an amazing year we
love you and we will see you in 2023.
we'll see you next year bye bye